underneath the handing of inequalities
the very first thing I want you to write
is just a little brief sentence for me
okay which is that inequalities da da
dot are just like equations except yeah
you'll love this except when they're the
opposite and I'll justify the statement
so what do we mean by inequality you've
been meeting event this room like
Cynthia seven we would say something
like the number five is bigger than the
number three okay so here's just a
statement of value one thing's bigger
than otherone thing smaller than another
or we could say five is greater than or
equal to three this is what we mean by
an inequality okay now we're going to be
dealing with some inequalities that
contain algebra in them and for that
reason if I gave you something like say
this okay what would you do with this
inequality give away not a horrible
question would you do you want courage
person come on I know your braids are
still warming up the Bissell room is
nice and good condition so what could I
do to both sides to get me started I'm
going to add one of our science and then
you divide by two now what you'll note
is that everything you just did I think
that you could have done if instead of
this question you had this question yeah
so you would do exactly the same steps
like it would literally be identical and
you would come up with an equivalent
sort of art good one so on good to see
you
grab a saving
so in other words what you've done from
line to line for this equation seems to
work just fine when you go from line to
line in an inequality and that's what I
mean by saying inequalities are just
like equations however even the word
itself in a closed it means not equal
this is like like the opposite of what
an equation is supposed to be okay so
I'm going to give you some examples I'm
going to pull them out of I'll use this
out of here one of the things that we do
or one of the things we did rather from
here to here is we divided the left and
right hand side by a number where we're
divided by in this case - you could
equally assembly multiplied by a number
we would have multiplied by 1/2 that
would have the same effect right well if
I multiply the left and right hand side
here by a different number like say oh I
don't know instead of 2 let's go with
say negative 2 all moves multiply so I'm
going to get this on the left hand side
and I'm going to get this on the right
hand side okay so I've done what we did
before I treated this just like an
equation I just kept it all balanced
right except of course you've realized
there's a problem here right there's a
greater than sign here but there
shouldn't be a greater than sign here
should there right so this is no longer
like an equation anymore it's got
direction to it whereas an equation has
no direction so this is different right
what about something else if I gave to
you say is a different question 1 over P
is equal to 4 what would you do with
that
P equals so I have we can have an answer
but what is it that you did in your mind
to actually get that answer because you
can cross multiply I suppose that would
leave you with one equals four P and
then and then what here let's see I
guess would divide both sides by four
yeah which is fine another way you could
just go directly from here to here
Morini graph is yes
excuse me another thing you could do to
get from here to here is just take the
reciprocal of both sides do you see that
that's what I've done from heating which
is a totally fine thing to do when you
have an equation okay let's come back to
this guy again what happens if I apply
similar logic if I take the reciprocals
of both sides I get 1/5 over here and
1/3 over here so which direction should
the inequality be facing it's going the
other way right just like with this we
notice that an operation like this
doesn't preserve the inequality in fact
it does exactly the opposite because of
this direction thing okay
so what we're going to work through this
morning are a few examples that try and
tease out the fact that equations and
inequalities share this DNA but in many
ways they are very very different
ok so here's our first example example 1
how many and I'm going to introduce a
symbol key which I've mentioned before
but it was a little while back so maybe
you can't remember it at all it's a
funky looking Zed with two bars in the
middle and a little plus in the corner I
wonder how many of you recall it and
then I'm going to introduce and
inequality and this is the inequality
that I've got
okay so does anyone remember what that
weird that means in a remember the Zed
stands for and I didn't tell you this
before I don't think anyway the Z stands
for the German word czar which just
means counting so the Z means integers
I'm pointing out that it stands for a
German word because people like said
integers boost
let's start with the same thing what
kind of abbreviation is this okay but
the Germans did a lot of fantastic
mathematics to do with integers so
that's why we kind of made this part
after them if these are integers right
we know they're whole numbers but the
integers also include the negatives so
this plus means don't include the
negatives I just want the positives okay
all right so this question is just how
many solutions are there as opposed to
what is the range of solution that I
want to do a count so tell me what shall
I do on the first line to get started on
this any takers
okay I can expand the can expand in this
case I'm not going to just yet because
have a think right it's always worth
looking at a question before you go to
your first instinct you think will this
make the question better or will it make
it worse
in this case expanding will make it
worse what else could I do
yeah doesn't okay I I can bring
everything over to one side I will
eventually get everything over to one
side the x's are going to eventually
become the subject of this inequality
but even simpler look at the left and
right hand side if something that should
be like slappy eventually yeah go ahead
hi I'm going to go even better than that
even simpler yeah okay so I think that
first most obvious choice is the Apes
okay I can't divide by two
I can't explain all these things are
fine but I'm interested in the most
efficient path through for example if
I've divided by 2 this would be
perfectly fine we get to the answer but
do you notice the next line I would have
1 2 3 4 objects still left behind right
and then I would have to simplify there
but if I subtract 8 from both sides but
I'm going to say that again
I'm subtracting 8 from both sides I'm
not moving
numbers back and forth that's sort of a
recipe for forgetting minus signs and
that kind of thing if I subtract 8 from
both sides then I immediately have
halved the number of terms that I'm
dealing with so that's a nice efficient
way to get through the question and you
can see now it's maybe a little more
obvious why I'm not going to expand what
can I do here I should divide right now
you do this I'm dividing by a negative
number so this kind of thing is going to
come to play right so when I divide by
negative 2 that leaves me with this and
this but what happens to the
inequalities direction changes in that
okay so far so good and now I can start
to rearrange I've gotten rid of all my
brackets and other extraneous things so
what would you like me to do I converted
you two things at once hold slightly to
do both sides good yep I think I going
to subtract 2x which will collect all of
my X's over here and at the same time
I'm also going to I'm going to add a
level which leaves me with 10 0 K
looking good so far one last step I'll
divide by 3 which gives me 10 over 3 now
I can write that as an improper fraction
there's nothing stopping me however in
this case we know lots of different ways
to write fractions right and we can
write them as decimals as percentages as
improper fractions which is at 10 over 3
was there's one more form what's the
other way I could write it I could write
as a mixed numeral what is 10 over 3 is
a mixed numeral 10 over 3 3 and 1/3
right now I just want you to contemplate
the fact that I could have written the
answer in any of those ways I could have
written it as 3 point 3 2 3 4 3 or 10
over 3 those would have been correct but
this is more helpful to me why
yeah have a look back at the original
question so what I'm just trying to
communicate here just a bit of an aside
is the form that you provide an answer
in is usually something that's in a test
given to you like we want it in this
form we want your equation in general
form we want your answer as a decimal
but it's mathematicians you have just
tools at your disposal and you get to
choose which is the most appropriate and
based on this question I think it's
easiest to think about it in these terms
so therefore what are the positive
integer solutions I might even say that
the positive integer solutions are well
what are they 1 2 & 3
therefore what's the actual odds are
there are three solutions always
important to return back to your
question and see if you got it